what's your comfort TV show Abbott
Elementary is pretty comfy my comfort
show is the Golden Girls better call Sal
Great British baking show always Jersey
Shore
hey hey that was working I'm working I
swear oh my gosh right now it's Gray's
Anatomy my comfort TV TV show is Golden
Girls scrubs Shadowhunters and Bad Girls
Club every season it's between avatar
The Last Airbender and Steven Universe
those are
My Cover TV show is uh RuPaul's Drag
Race One Tree Hill my comfort TV show is
the office specifically the fire drill
episode it is season five episode 14. it
makes me laugh uncontrollably every
single time no matter how many times I
watch it you're the worst South Park
Next Level Chef 30 Rock is my show my
age buddy Sabrina the Teenage Witch